because I feel like everybody always
treats actor it's like as they probably
should emotional like landmine there it
is basic telling your raggedy never know
what's going to set them off and it's
just a job like any other you look how
do you look and be comfortable like what
are you going to do be hungry every
single day to make other people happy
that's just dumb - in my mind she's so
lovely and picturesque and then I talk
back about it I'm like oh my god she's
the highest-paid actress in the world
and her films have grossed over 5
billion dollars
she had her breakthrough in 2010 playing
a poverty-stricken teenager in the
independent film Winter's Bone in 2013
she was listed in Time Magazine's 100
most influential people in the world
she's Jennifer Lawrence and here's my
take on her top ten rules of success
rule number one is my personal favorite
I make sure to stick around although to
the eggs of some special bonus clips
also as Jennifer is talking if you said
something that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
hi I'm Jennifer Lawrence have you been
hiding under a rock how would you not
know that I always had this really gross
dangerous mentality of the no
consideration of failure just never even
considering the thought of failing like
if I want something I just go until I
get it
and that doesn't always work good
the interesting thing for me to talk to
you and what makes you so fascinating is
the talent that you see on the screen
but but at the same time there is a
certain innocence and yet a certain
power and it seems to me it's both
artists and also business well thank you
would you believe that yeah all right
that's time for it's very hard to make
that is not true so thank you but it's
low-fat thank you well because without
gaining some sort of control over the
business I lose some control over those
over creative which is most important
how I you control of the business the
more you can give flower to the creative
exactly I'll give links to the creation
yeah so I used to stay out of it I don't
care I know I ain't earnest I don't need
it you know and so this is my business
now and as it may you know it is
important at my agent that my agent
always says I mean I'm his only client
and I'm for call them back as soon as he
is my business and I respect my choice
is visual so laquanda calls him back to
city Utley means I am is calling I'm
doing probably the only I returned
emails or return phone calls because
because you want to know what the
options there are yes I've worked really
hard to build this and I want to
continue building it and it's my
business my personal business so I don't
understand how people do slack I'm
really annoying with with how I choose
things because it's really like a
feeling which just sounds
stupid but sometimes I've read scripts
before that have let I just recently I
read a script that I was sobbing I've
never been so moved by a story and I
thought it was the most beautiful
amazing sir and I just couldn't wait
this movie to get made so that the world
could see it but I just wasn't her I
wasn't the character and I couldn't and
I also had an experience once where I
read a script and I loved it but I
couldn't stop picturing Amanda Seyfried
and Johnny Mills the people and I was
like you gotta hire Amanda Seyfried for
this I couldn't stop picturing it so a
lot of it is the things that he said he
want to be a part of a good film and you
want to be make a good movie but there's
also a huge emotional component for me
that I don't know how to describe it
it's just kind of sometimes something
clicked and I feel like that person does
in a weird way exists and he and
something stupid thing to say that and
sometimes it just doesn't and sometimes
I can read a character and absolutely
love her but I know that I could never
I'm not her something I don't know
so how was the experience of being
directed by David finally immediately a
dream come true because when you're such
a huge fan on somebody who build it up
so much in your head you're always
prepared to be let down but he was just
a nicest warmest sweetest state person
in the entire world it has such a warm
good energy and and then he he just
directed this I've never worked that way
and that's an incredible thing to do is
to kind of realize that there's no one
or right way to make a movie or direct
an actor so what did he do something
that you particularly like that you
haven't yeah he would interrupt like any
monologue no matter what it was no
matter how serious he was hope oh it's
such bullsh
it's so bad it's so bad it's like
alright do it again it's just like so
funny just be able to like because you
can be honest like on this a whole new
level I get that's why Bradley and I
don't want to stop working together
because we can fight we can just be like
don't say that don't wear that what are
you doing I boss each other around
yeah I like it not wasting diamond to
say cutting the [ __ ] and just
getting real and because I feel like
everybody always treat actor it's like
that as they probably should emotional
like landline there it is basic telling
arrives you never know that's going to
set them off and it's just a job like
any other like you sometimes you're
going to be good and sometimes you can
be bad like just I like it when
someone's like that was bad
do it again so what so what he's saying
that he's not just saying about Asia is
mostly about you guys not about his
scriptor no it's never about us scraps
all you got our performance is just
missile yeah yeah just like you were
really bad how does a scariest part of
my job as the gamble of reading a script
which one do you do who makes it you
never know you can read an amazing
script and hire a director who seemed
fantastic and then an amazing co-star
and you can be on set and be completely
out of control and watch it either fall
apart or you can love it and then
audiences don't respond you know and
then there's in there there are certain
there is planning over here you know if
you're going to have this movie come out
what follows that and then what you know
and that's the most stressful part of my
job because it is a gamble but it's
important to me that I'm that I do make
those decisions
I don't want an agent's career or a
lawyers career I want I need advice I
have an amazing agent and I really
respect his opinion but I would never do
it's all my entire career is dictated by
a feeling and I've gone to great lengths
to try and make sure that it stays that
way of shed big parts of my team because
I don't want more people to say no to I
first you good thank you and sometimes
I'm wrong and when you're wrong what do
you think happened kind of things fine
that happens in business and ups and
downs I would might rather blame myself
though and go I shouldn't have listened
to that person at least I go well you
learned you know why many doors did it
turned out to be the wrong hands you
know what I just started and I had no
idea what I was doing I didn't know what
else to do I don't know how to act I
just know how to talk and I think once I
started understanding on
I don't really want to learn how to act
I just want to keep learning on the top
and I've always just kind of such as
people studier and I think that for me
the best schooling I could have ever
gotten was watching and listening the
world to the world I mean just watching
people talk watching people do different
things so many of the things that I do
on screen are things that I've seen
other people do that I thought were
interesting you know like funny things
with people's mouths or when they're
upset the things they do with their
hands like this one time I um I can't
but my friends was crying and she was so
fat she put her hands up and she didn't
know what to do with them and they were
shaking and I was comforting her but at
the same time I was in some cool so yeah
I know that what did you do right there
so I I had an emotional scene in Pokhara
house and almost every time I cried I
did that with my hands and and I don't
know I just pick up from from people
having experienced the body made
criticism in Hollywood what is your
advice to young girls dealing with the
same treatment from their peers and the
songs to those who judge others based on
appearances most screw those people no
in it oh thanks
yeah I mean it's something that
everybody experiences you know I
experienced it in school before I was
saying it's just the world has a certain
idea of you know we see this airbrushed
perfect model and then if you don't look
like that
you're and it's just too easy for people
you know I mean I've got a million ideas
coming at the same time but you just
have to you have to look past it you
look how you look and be comfortable
like what are you going to do be hungry
every single day to make other people
happy that's just dumb and you know this
shows like the Fashion Police and things
like that or just showing these
generations of young people to judge
people based on things that you know
they put values and all the things that
are wrong and that it's okay to just
point at people and call them ugly and
call them fat and they call it fun and
welcome to the real world and it's like
that shouldn't be the real world it's
going to keep being the real world if we
keep it that way it's not until we stop
treating each other like that and just
stop calling it a fad call you know with
these unrealistic expectations for women
it's disappointing that the media keeps
it alive and fuels that fire as
something that really bothers me because
I love eat hey wouldn't it take to be a
great actress because that performance
in your movie is a really great
performance I say by any yardstick what
does she have genocide but it takes it
to that kind of level well I think
there's a sorrowful nostalgically
there if you don't you're not it's right
there in her eyes and in her face and
then her the way she talks I don't know
how to express it except to point to her
performance I mean she has a sense
fulness that comes from her than and
there's a Ameri embarrass her ass and I
just think she took real concern she was
too long for the world and I said she
almost was a timeless quality to her
which I go through I thought oh man she
seems like she's a chance and legends
like she's 40
not only that a realness the lack of
preciousness it was not a framer and
she's doing it's raw and it's real
it comes from part of her store and and
she just channeled it right out there
and she's not she weren't afraid to jump
in and do it any number of different
ways and she'll touch is very good
instincts she'll tell you when she she
was something with salt and what you'd
like to find another way we'll do it but
it's a great gift to a director to have
an actor who has so much emotion readily
available it's authentic emotion it's
from its from her and it's a part of her
and I hope and it you know I just don't
know how its is impressing pass a
mention of it and she's already created
a kind of legacy to be bold in your life
there was a girl she met on the first
Hunger Games a burn survivor who had
scars all over her body she said I love
my body because I'm I'm the girl on fire
it made her feel strong and brave and I
just started crying she gave me such a
gift and I'm just acting but it made me
feel like if a character or a story can
make something to change a perception on
how they feel about themselves and that
is beautiful for a generation of tiny
fans one message believe in yourself
hydroponic or farm so I wrote a lot of
horses which I hear you like yes oh yeah
I do I hear you hate horses
oh are you drunk
no I just would have been a very weird
thing I hate horses no I don't like
people who know I like it yeah but I
have you ride then right yeah I do every
ever fallen off a been thrown yeah
because my parents were cheap so they
never bought trained horses so it was
just kind of I have a deformed tailbone
actually something's thrown off of a
horse you know I'd heard that no no wait
a minute you're telling me that your
parents bought wild unbroken stallion
because they were cheaper and let the
kids loose on them yeah they were busy
they had more thing for a man oh yeah of
course
so then you had to break your own horse
yeah or my own tailbone yeah and where
you toss two that were kicked everything
one of my eyes the horses running into a
barn like an abandoned barn so I had to
just jump ship well and dropping a roll
but that was a deformed elbow did it in
Kentucky is it did they ride a western
or English sound like such a redneck I
don't really rewrite a saddle if we did
we have English and western saddles but
my mom said that that was for the people
who like forwards or horses there so I
wasn't allowed to use any of that so I
just kind of hopped on and went for it
good idea yeah
did anybody from the county ever come
out to the house
hi file ahead in my mind seems so lovely
and picturesque and I talk back about it
I'm like oh my god you kids doing them
sandals now get out there drinkin bro
that's right politic oh my goodness yeah
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because mr. playthroughs
101 asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know what did you take
from this video what did Jennifer say
that has the biggest impact on you that
you're going to make an immediate change
to your business or your life leave it
in the comments I'm going to join in the
conversation I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kem Oh tada ho thank you so
much for picking up a cup of my book
dear one word and taking that awesome
picture with the Eiffel Tower I really
really really appreciate it so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one where it
is much love please
yeah I mean I was very fortunate I
started working I started trying to work
at 14 and I know I was at home I was 16
I dealt was a lot of nose mostly
personal nose you know whether my family
it's hard for 14 year old to say I'm
leaving in Kentucky I'm moving to New
York but I knew I felt so strongly it
feels insane to be a teenager and no I
knew that it was the right thing to do
anyway that it was going to work out so
they all know I wouldn't be supportive
of my teenager as Ike I'm living in New
York I thought I would say you know we
thought I was going to get killed I'm
surprised I didn't get killed but it was
like a fire and also this like I just
knew it so I eventually saved that
babysitting money and went and did it
and so were you
what was the first time you felt really
challenged to come up with something
that was that much harder to do for you
what do you mean well I mean it seems
like something like burning bad for
instance it's really tough roll it's not
a you know I came out my family family
in the street of New York and told me to
be an actress and Here I am yeah or was
it I mean was it just that natural to
you or did it was I think I think it
actually helped me because I didn't
really go to any classes or feeder
schools or anything like that so I
didn't really know how to act
I just mean had a talk and then I just
knew I don't know I think I was able to
build my instincts better and I learned
from a lot of mistakes I can look back
on things now that well if you learned
from that I don't know I think I think
it was it so hard for me to answer
because I haven't I haven't thought
about it as much as you guys have so
that's always true